you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman chess calm
and I just got paired up playing a 3-2
game okay
let's start out with you four and we're
gonna have Carroll Khan clearly I like
going for the exchange variation so
let's start with this and I'm gonna play
it in a way where I restrict their
LightSquared Bishop so that's why first
Bishop d3 and on Knight to f6 h3 so they
could still play Bishop to f5 I've seen
this idea before with g6 Bishop f5 let's
see hmm
let's start first with Knight f3 and I'm
going to delay castling because I have
an idea in mind with playing g4 let's
see I could take I could damage their
structure it's not really that big of a
deal this is their good bishop mm-hmm
yeah let's go straight in for it and
play Bishop to f4 I don't know if this
is so great
I know I've reviewed this before with
the computer but now recalling the
variations so 95 hmm yeah let's go
Knight to e5 right now neglecting
development with this move clearly but I
want to I want to be able to pivot on
the d3 square okay they're putting
immediate pressure on the G file so
they're not going to Castle kingside
I wonder if I could still just Castle
kingside I know I'm going right into the
line of fire hmm
I'm not sure mm-hmm
this nights gonna be a bother when he
gets into f4 yeah maybe maybe I should
go queenside let's start out with this
g3 I really don't want to devote a piece
to defending my Jeep on I'm already
thinking about castling
queenside so okay they go in for an
immediate exchange there hmm that's a
bit of a bug I think I need to challenge
that night right away he's in my
position try and get rid of him
mmm he's not easily kicked away though
you know I can't play f3 because I
dropped g3 really didn't get anything
out of this opening they played a very
quick Bishop to f5 I was more used to
seeing it after like let's say a Bishop
g7 and castles so to take the knight or
the bishop let's take helping them to
develop but mm-hmm
maybe can I work around that night
hmm Knight to f3 he's yeah I'm gonna try
to work around that night I guess they
could force my hand eventually they
could defend the e5 square with f6 but
that weakens the e6 square my plan here
is just to complete development Queen e2
queenside castle expecting a queen move
here Queen b6 Queen e2 shouldn't be any
bother okay so I'm gonna have to do that
they're gonna be sacrifices on g3 we're
gonna see on f4 I'm prepared to meet
that with g4 okay and I think I need to
get castled real soon I'm expecting
these two moves I'm within striking
distance now or this Knight is within
checking distance is what I meant and I
think I need to overprotect c3 because
of sacrifices and then ensuing Forks so
maybe a knight maneuver with 91 into d3
I should probably get out of this pin
Knightly one to d3 h5 might be a move so
that on f4 I can't play g4 although this
isn't supported enough just yet
am i tactically vulnerable with a 91 my
rooks are disconnected for just one move
I don't think so
am I missing anything let's sneak that
in there might be sacrifice as soon
happening on the c3 square this night is
still a great bother he cannot be kicked
with f3
hmm I don't think there's any sacrifices
working on c3 just yet now I could think
about was like g4 and then f3 although
no Knight here whether he's taking upon
her he's landing a fork but I could
still start with g4 my Knights in a good
spot
if this Knight moves I have Knight c5
and then maybe there might be ideas or
95 and be three if this night is no
longer round putting pressure on c3 okay
they've officially have every piece
hitting the c3 pawn hmm preparing Brooke
to a four maybe
okay
that's a bit tricky let's start with
this I think I want to maybe play rook
b4 all right should be night before on
rook to a4 just thinking rook c1 first
let's do this
I know I'm crawling up into a ball
I could still think now I can't do this
move anymore
mmm I think I have to do this less than
10 seconds they have all these minor if
he are all these major pieces coming
right at me here I still want to get
this in now I'm finally ready to kick
the knight sacrifice
on this square I have lateral defense
with my queen we're gonna see I don't
like to calculate it
I could have considered this maybe I
should do this right now actually now
let's try this
throw in some aggressive move right
maybe King a 2 and then B 3 is an idea
let's see where the rook goes f3 f3 mmm
rook b6 King a - let's do this
threatening b3 maybe f3 I could take and
then f3 let me let's take first get that
night out of there finally Knight year I
could take this pawn I'm not going to
though probably should have moved
forward I'm expecting f4 you need to get
rid of this pawn queen here now my
knight needs this square let's get over
here
I should have put immediate pressure on
this pond ok I'm putting pressure here
now I think I have my king side defended
maybe just pile up on this pawn try and
win this guy major piece ending alone
should be good okay it's
fiying I welcome more exchanges you've
got to crawl up into a ball Queen B 3
happening
stay out of pins stay off of the beef
I'll defend my back rank
let's not blunder a rook this is big
trouble I want to trade Queens not easy
how can I get my Queen active I guess
here Queen d6 maybe the very first act
of move Queen d6 it is although I don't
even know what I'm threatening I could
just take the F pawn
take here and then play here I think I
have everything defended barely my queen
is actually central let's start with
this I guess and then this is a past
pond so maybe you get them pushing yeah
let's keep going I have to watch this
diagonal here just throw this check in I
want to take the a pond with check is
able to do that not here just yet
because my queen is unprotected okay
this gives some more checks take the
spawn whit's check and now advance
so this is I finally think I know how to
win this I have this diagonal check
covered or this open diagonal covered
queenie 7 just trading queens and then
pushing away okay they resigned let me
step away from this let me check it out
with the computer i'm pretty sure
there's a tactic that my opponent could
have had here and they just missed it
and that was very very stressful but
yeah let me bring up stock fish and
we'll see what it has to say on this one
okay let's see where there are some
improvements i got zero out of the
opening in fact i believe my opponent
there was a quick transition with you
know went beyond equal my opponent
quickly equalized and then i think had a
slight advantage and we'll see where
there were some tactics missed is there
any other move being suggested here and
likes Bishop takes Bishop within the
follow-up okay Bishop f4 he's six how
could I've done something different
because didn't feel too good it's
pressure on the G file and the night on
that e4 square was a great bother okay
it's still around even ish it prefers
Queen b3 here with Queen b6 I would have
been happy to see that right can I get
away with
this actually maybe I'm not even in time
to prevent this unmov'd before yeah I'm
not quite there hmm 1p wooden Queen d7
be fine
you know this Knight is a little bit
loose so on this move Knight takes
Bishop takes and it's not a great bother
this is a fine structure I have some
experience with this in over the board
play not just blitz play but this these
double deaf pawns and the half open G
file very solid structure usually this
pawn is still on this square but see all
the all the more well I think it's even
better having the pawn on d5 and c6 in
this case strong grip over the e4 square
but okay Queen b3 instead I played 95 it
wants to castle okay yeah I didn't
castle so this is probably where there's
gonna be a pretty good shift
g3 no nothing so wrong with that
still pretty even ish right there yeah
it's slightly better for black not by
much
okay where were their tactics missed
okay pretty even position nothing
nothing missed so far but I imagine when
both the rooks their queen and Knight
we're breathing down my Kings neck here
there was something missed so let's see
where there was was some tactical shot
oh he takes d4 right here and I was even
pointing it out are there any tactics if
my knight goes here and my rooks are
disconnected for just a moment there is
91 Queen takes d4 yeah okay so Queen
takes d4 we both missed that Knight d3
and now it's back to pretty even we both
have really nice nicely placed Knights
maybe give the nod to my knight over
this one as he's not so easily kicked
from the d3 square he still it takes
takes forever to get this Knight out of
here though got to move the rook to get
out of these uh forks I got to move my
Jeep on and then finally f3 once I did
manage that I thought I was the better
side here so it's uh it's actually
liking white all of a sudden like c5
here for black I think at this point
black was probably and I would be too
they're just content with keeping the
pawn structure as is just playing with
pieces in other words is black right now
so II five maybe just didn't even come
to mind and then we have a three yeah
for a second I was thinking I could I
could play this but yeah c3 is hit still
three times Queen rook and Knight still
has it as even why is that rook takes f3
oh that's a tough move to make the
knee-jerk reaction is just to take back
but it's losing the farm
ouch yeah okay so I played a three and
it's liking light here now certainly
under a lot of pressure
f3 right away did not consider that heli
g4 nothing wrong with that on f3 Knight
takes Queen e1 oh yeah and I'm night
here Queen h4 okay I didn't have time to
think of that stuff but the big thing
here is that this night is really a a
super piece if I didn't get him here in
time I imagine there would would have
been some tactical shot that black would
have against my king position but he's
really just an enormous piece these
pivot points b4
see for sometime z5 although it's taken
away right now f4 is another nice
forward move throwing nice punches in
some way so got g4 in through a night
before it is liking the white side takes
finally the night is kicked Queen d2
instead still holding an advantage
thanks B 3 here winning the exchange I
didn't even see that huh
okay you want instead an ID three and
I'm still holding something here I'm
getting that material and in this major
piece ending alone was there any tactic
missed crawling up into a ball once
again
and still holding an advantage this
major piece ending and now I'm winning
with this very variation it's a million
nine oh why didn't I consider just
taking or I'm giving a check here you
know clean c5 it's a million nine
already b6 rookie 7 etc okay I just took
the pawn I was I think that quick
thought that I had here was okay this
rook d1 move is gonna be played and
we're gonna be into a a queen ending
alone and I wanted to overprotect this
diagonal so I don't know that I let it
slip even in this ending even though I
didn't get that mate but yeah this is
this is holding so aside I guess from
the that tactical shot for that one
moment with what was that point here
with Queen d4 as soon as I did that
night reposition there was one one
tactical shot that black had there but
apparently this was holding again this
is a very good square to be made aware
of for a knight and queen takes d4 here
was the I'm still having a Z about even
ish this Knight coming into d3 still
once the knight is kicked east six may
be an issue as well but yeah that was
one tactic that black had that his
knight on d3 is a super super piece
right behind this pawn excellent pivot
squares and yeah did a good job clearly
holding uh I think he prevented
the tactics that would have been
available against the kingside being on
this is d3 squared but anyhow feel free
to leave any comments in the comment
section below to this video and as
always I hope you got something out of
it that's all for now take care bye
you